the normalization is in full swing the
transition is complete the days of there
was no collusion there were no
conversations with Russia are over for
the Trump administration
I warned you three weeks ago the tune
was changing on krump Russia from the
right the old position was there was no
collusion the new position is it's not
illegal and everyone does it a reminder
this is when we started seeing the tide
turn Brit Hume on Fox News was one of
the first to use this what what but what
crime how do you identify the crime
collusion well as obviously be alarming
and highly inappropriate for the Trump
campaign of which there's no evidence by
the way of colluded with the Russians
it's not a crime so that was then the
old new position collusion wouldn't be a
crime the new new position is collusions
normal it's been months and months of
complete and total denials that there
was ever anything going on with Russia
everyone in the Trump campaign has been
saying it for months if not longer
remember what Kellyanne Conway herself
said in January
did anyone involved in the Trump
campaign have any contact with Russians
trying to meddle with the election
absolutely not and I discussed that with
the president-elect just last night
those conversations never happen I hear
people saying it like it's a fact on
television that is just not only
inaccurate and false but it's dangerous
is the president aware it does undermine
our democracy Mike Pence exactly the
same tune that he's been singing for a
long time did any adviser or any way in
the Trump campaign have any contact with
the Russians who are trying to meddle in
the election of course not and now the
new position from the horse's mouth
himself Donald Trump tweeting yesterday
collusion is normal quote most
politicians would have gone to a meeting
like the one Don junior attended in
order to get info on an opponent that's
politics wasn't things are going to go
way more smoothly if Donald Trump admits
that they did this it didn't happen but
if it did it wasn't bad and if it was
bad Hillary did it too and if
that doesn't matter then I wasn't
personally involved and if I was
personally involved I had no idea what I
was doing and if I did know what I was
doing I guess the voters deserve what
they got
well obviously political campaigns look
for opposition research but where the
difference comes in is where you get
that source from I mean most campaigns
don't look to foreign governments and
adversarial governments at that for that
information and now you have people even
like Chris Christie who's a Republican
governor saying that that was probably
illegal what Don jr. did a dozen or so
Republicans said oh no that's not normal
I would not take that meeting do not
allow this to be normalized their
original position has evaporated into
thin air they now have a new position
the idea is very clear it's a concerted
effort to normalize what happened you'll
hear the mention Hillary Clinton's
campaign and something about Ukraine
you'll hear them mention oh there was no
crime committed trump has now fully
embraced the position that they colluded
with a foreign country but that it's
totally unremarkable in every way and
first of all there is no one on the
Trump team that is qualified to tell us
what is normal period right that's first
of all
first up if others did it even if that's
true that's not a defense you can't
defend your killing of other people by
saying I'm not the only person who's
murdered you don't get let off of
drunk-driving charges because you aren't
the only person to drive drunk it's a
red herring and it is not something that
should be considered and lastly as Pat
is pointing out it might well be illegal
we will hopefully continue to learn more
over the coming days and weeks about
that but it will may be illegal and it's
really the Republican Party that should
be ashamed here I mean just an absolute
and total disregard for what's right
will they stand by him indefinitely or
will they start to bail some are
starting to go in the direction of
bailing and that that's actually a good
thing the video you just watched was
made possible by support from you please
go to patreon.com/scishow you can make a
pledge of as little as $1 per month and
every dollar helps to support the work
that we're doing particularly in light
of the YouTube ad boycott which has been
really bad